[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as us chess champs dot-com
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome back to day
two of the summer chess classic as
always I'm joined by the wonderful
Grandmaster Jessie cry and we're here to
talk about hopefully some more exciting
games today
I know day one was certainly kind of a
thriller thriller for both of us it was
a day for upsets actually with David
Howell upsetting the number one seed in
a group Sam Shanklin so you're a game
ghoulia actually upsetting Egor
Kovalenko who's the number two seed in
the B group and the young Brandon
Jacobson actually taking on Christian
shrila and winning his match and those
are the only three decisive games
actually
so those three players are now out in a
clear lead right and we can actually
take a look at those standings and see
where everybody sits right now of course
David Howell with that win over Sam
Shanklin catapults to the front of the a
group and clear first followed by a
Gowen Jones
Liam Lee Jeffrey Zhang and Darius Swedes
all with a draw in round one and
unfortunately for Sam he he pressed very
hard in that first game and it kind of
came back to haunt Simon so he rounds
out the a group and now over the B group
standings we actually have Surya Ganguly
in first place with his win over Egor
Kovalenko and following him or of course
Sam Savion Daniel Friedman Grigory
Oberon and Havana's boots Ian and in the
C group we have Brandon Jacobson
actually the lowest rated player of all
the sections in this event winning his
round one game and getting into clear
first followed by Dmitry Gordievsky our
turfs Naik Suns are on Paco bian L Shan
Moratti a body and of course Christian
sure illa we can actually take a look at
the tournament format see what kind of
time controls these players are squaring
off in it is actually three there are
three six player double round robins so
of course everyone will play everyone
else twice in each of the groups
the time control for this event is game
in 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
with 30 minutes sudden-death past move
40 they also have a 30 second increment
and move one and there is also a 30 move
draw rule in effect so no drawers before
move 30 unless by repetition
now we can take a look at the schedule
see what it looks like it's not too
complicated for this event basically
just one game a day with a rest day in
the middle and you can always find us
here
of course at 3:30 two and a half hours
after each round starts and you can
watch along on youtube.com slash the st.
Louis chess club you can follow the
games live on us chess champ calm and
you can kind of interact with us in the
YouTube chat through Twitter using the
hashtag summer chess classic and of
course on the chess 24 chat on us chess
chance calm and with that in mind let's
just jump right into the pairings for
group a we have Jeffrey Zhang fighting
against Li Emily Gawain Jones playing
Sam Jenkins and our key matchup of the
day leader David Howell is taking on
Darius wits and we can take a look at
that game and see how it has progressed
thus far yeah let's take a look I
thought so how will played a beautiful
game against Sam yesterday and I thought
he did a very clever thing in the
opening I was up there watching it and
like with Sam in the early going he said
he's clearly aware of these openings but
he's thinking about them like he's
choosing them as he's playing them he's
not like he's figured it out before
which is kind of an interesting thing to
me it's very creative and what he did
here was black plate Knight b6 and
normally black this is fine but normally
the knight the white knight is already
on c3 in these variations mm-hm
so how will decided okay you know what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna turn this in
- like Dragon Hedgehog what I mean by
dragon head targets normally in the
hedgehog imagine with reverse colors
you'll have a structure with d3 and III
and B 3 and a 3 but here we have the
bishop on g2 which can be an advantage
however you know when you play e3 the d3
pawn will be a weakness now it's going
to be a roughly equal position but a
very much a fighting positional game and
so it went like this kind of I think as
how we'll probably expected it to go and
here III and I thought it's roughly
equal but I liked White's position a lot
because the the whole thing with the
Hedgehog right is those pawns
beautifully control blacks miners
usually it's with reversed colors and
what it does is it forces black to do
something if he doesn't do something
slowly the pieces are going to converge
especially eventually a night landing on
a square like c5 94 to c5 so now things
become concrete Queen f8 and maybe
Howell should have thought about d4 here
but okay rook K was ignoring the a upon
us right rook d7 and then how goes for
it now he didn't need to but he went for
it with d4 and here the violence begins
right we had a it's you know it's a
funny thing about chess you can play
positional stuff but now the position is
going to get violent and it's we're
gonna run into a totally different
position now here and let's just stop
for a moment here and say a couple
dogmatic things the bishop on g2 is
beautiful right it's working well with
the pawns and because black and white
has more pawns around his King he can
make an argument that his King is going
to be safer in the long
of course black is making a claim about
especially this pawn being very strong
and this pawn of being weak and maybe
just we're gonna take the two bishops
and have a joyful day so here's the
situation that we're gonna run into the
game where rook a b1 I'm sure how will
thought about what happened next right
which was what are you gonna do a black
just does that it's the most natural
right just take off the bishop and then
use the dark squares and this this
frightens me a lot but let's consider
now his move Queen c2 we just played in
the game now and think about what's
going on clearly he is going to lose the
Acorn and black can obviously take it in
two different ways and arguably he's not
even in any rush to take this thing so
the question is what is White's
intention what's the point why I kind of
allow the C pawn to get kind of so
dangerously far down the board and with
the a pawn falling let's think about it
for saying so imagine rook takes right
let's call that the most natural move
and I think one thought here is to ask
black if he wants to weaken if if in how
he wants to weep in the position and
then maybe take on b7
I really wouldn't mind playing f5 here I
think okay but bear in mind that will
weaken the e5 square for them my knight
and actually when we come back a second
it's that white it's the night that I is
white I'm really upset about more than
losing the part I'm upset that you've
taken away the square from my knight so
mighty good job so at least if you play
f5 my knight will have some thoughts and
he already has some thoughts with going
f3 and D for my claim was just gonna be
that I can put the Bishop on f6 after I
play f5 and use that on a post Bishop to
kind of keep the
in check no I think it's all gonna be
fair I'm just trying to figure out like
what the idea is
sure right rook a3 and besides Bishop b4
I don't know what else and this would
previous then I mean it's very hard to
calculate this kind of thing because
there really are f5 is plausible g6 is
plausible h6 as possible and f5 doesn't
really win a temple because I think I
have to take on b7 anyway yeah I'm a
little I'm a little confused though
because even if there is some idea here
I don't see how white can actually ever
be any better right it just looks looks
like black has the bishops and I don't
think the C pawn is really gonna prove
to be to be weakness I think it's I
think the white can make a claim that he
never he never claimed he was better
anyway
okay he never said he was better he just
wanted a position that's interesting and
it is it is interesting where the black
the idea is gonna be white black is
obviously gonna push the pawns and have
the bishops but now some kind of
weakness has to happen with the black
King and we're gonna head into time
trouble with that weakness see there is
a question is the C pawn falling for
black but I don't know let's let's look
at that so one thing here is on Knight
c4 I actually tried to make this work
but I couldn't which was rook c7 and
then let's say Bishop d5 I didn't know
what else to do yeah and let's say
snip-snip
and then rook c8 I didn't see a way to
stop it stop my knight from fall that
looks pretty dangerous yeah but maybe in
some variations right this could
actually end up working
maybe after there it takes on a three
I'm sure he looked on it you know but I
think now it's you know after Queen c2
it's not gonna oh you're saying after
rook a3 maybe then Knight see for me
yeah I wasn't sure here this says it's a
thought it looks pretty shaky but no at
least it's something that that black has
to think about so it yeah let's just say
that in this position after Queen c2
Queen C did a clever move which makes
black worry about precisely that like
depending on how you take maybe I get a
good z4 and you have to worry about
Bishop before
and this is the career position yeah and
I'll say this about how what I like
about his place he seems to me a very
cunning player right the way he set up
sets up the openings it's not about
being objectively right it's about
messing with your opponent and that's
definitely how he chose his opening in
Shanklin yesterday and the trick the
trickiness with which he played that
position it how do you know how do you
think you can kind of explain his choice
to thanks so much in the opening is he
just deciding how he feels on that day
deciding how he thinks his opponent
feels how he just wants to play I would
love at some point to get him in down
here and talk to him about that kind of
thing absolutely
he feels just looking at it and the
moves he makes he it feels like he's
approaching it like an artist hmm that's
what it feels like to me yeah definitely
some inspired play today today and as
well as yesterday from David Howell well
let's let Darius think on his choices
here and take a look actually at the B
group sugar have going on there with the
pairings so Daniel Friedman was playing
Eve or a couple on coke but they
actually had a rather quick draw today
Sam 7 is paired against Grigory Oberon
and our key matchup of the day is
caboose Ian against our B group leader
Surya Ganguly so we can take a look at
what's going on on the board witness
interesting stuff yeah this this
position that they have there I got
Ganguly to me looks to have them much
better of it and maybe we'll go back and
talk about what happened
yeah so let's start at the opening so
lots of taken away maybe we should find
the path there so we start off with this
NIM so and in general Bishop g5 is wrong
in general obviously the booth Ian has
some ideas the reason it's wrong is that
if I kick you with h6 what do you want
to do and part of it is honestly a dogma
and dogmatic thing of bishops before
Knights because you're not sure where
that Bishop wants to go with the bishop
on the dark square bishop right
I think the idea though at least the way
it played out in this game was to make a
weird claim that by getting you to play
h6 didn't even have to blaze explode but
by getting you to do that I've now
gotten a lever to later strike out with
g4 g 5c so the point is just a he's kind
of telegraphing that he wants to attack
on the kingside then by a I mean I'm
making black touches Kings side one let
me just say I as black I think this is
beautiful this black I think this is way
to do this so black does the normal
nimza thing here and he goes and scoops
the pawn and grabs the e4 square 92 94
and this feels complicated but when you
think about it it's just like piling on
the pinned piece right it's just kind of
basic principles well actually yeah and
notice now black just got this on a post
bishop right and that's going to be a
feature of the game to come castles they
should be 70 keeps it 94 now a very
simple and beautiful plan here a 6 g 4 B
5 and it's a simple thing well
the calculation is very complicated but
the ideas here are very simple in that
whoever in general gets the initiative
on the opposite sides castling is going
to win so black is fine with sacking a
pawn on the Queen side
let's look at how it goes rook g1 b4
snip-snip and white house in order to
prevent Bishop c3 which you should just
give the guy maybe should give it to him
anyways he plays Knight b3 Queen e5 + 9
a - so the Knights this position is
gonna evolve obviously but the Knights
first of all it just doesn't look right
to say the black of the most I've
centralized Queen looks great
and this g4 g5 is scary but the Knights
of course are not on the attack the only
claim black can make is something about
the Knights being good defenders but
honestly they're gonna have to come back
I thought black had many different moves
here even the simple rook b8 I'm sure
would have been a good move but it seems
to me like white is using the two
knights in place of the one bishop that
I gave up earlier right like you could
take off the two knights and put a
bishop on c3 and the White King might be
safer yeah so this I feel like there's
some really interesting classical play
that ganguly is going to do here that it
takes a lot of courage to do because
what he's gonna do is he's gonna take a
moment a time out to just secure his
King site and it's scary because
normally it's like you know the the
formula is crushed on the Queen side and
don't even mess with your weak side but
watch what he does h4 and 98 so he's
gonna make a claim that there's gonna be
no entrance on the Queen's of the Kings
side 94 Bishop d7 G v h5 Bishop d3 g 6
so notice the last several moves black
has made no attempt to do anything on
the Queen side but rather he's making
this long-term claim that if he can
solidify on the King side that the game
will be strategically won because
eventually I'm gonna come to the Queen
side and my bishop right this one in
particular is going to be a
yes so I did want to ask briefly so the
point of 98 isn't that it defendants
squares but on g5 there's no longer the
temple on the night so that gives you
this option to play h5n kind of close it
down right to not have your Kings side
open right with g5 that's absolutely
right and I'm sure there were other
things to do
but this is very old-school right notice
blacks all of blacks moves have just
been tending to his own King sign right
here
rook abiud here comes Knight at for now
let's just say what white is deciding
here with neither for is that eventually
he will have to sac on g6 and that is in
principle correct whether or not it's
actually gonna work he has to do
something against the black King because
the there's like a time bomb ticking on
the White Queen sine Queen a fine if we
go back King D to bold this is obviously
let's just call this what it is it's
desperation Bishop f3 Queen b6 and here
we are very unpleasant position
excellently played by Ganguly where I
don't see the sac happening on g6 the
bishop on e7 is beautiful and here we
actually have a couple moves being
played actually a bunch of us play the
b-pawn look for okay - now now things
are of course heating up in all these
rounds they should be six they should be
five oh that was nice that was very nice
the pieces just keep improving and now
we're gonna say you can take the part if
you want rook FC eight
and he does take on b2 now so let's just
look the point is like the the endgame
is completely lost because the king the
white king will continue to be under
attack right so white plays Knight e4
and I think that one of the big
challenges for ganguly here is you have
so many nice options but you only have
12 minutes I just want to say I admire
this game a lot and I especially admire
the way he activated the dark square
bishop to be part of this attack here
and solidified the King it's it's over
there's no more King side attack for
white now so we just need to do
something about our bishop and so the
big problems for a white I guess are
just the the King safety and then maybe
the this advanced structure on the Kings
side pushing h4 and g5 kind of makes
some weaknesses
yeah there's weaknesses all over yeah
but white I mean he still needs to play
good moves there and what White's trying
to make is some kind of claim that this
bishop doesn't have a good square
honestly it seems like he has multiple
good squares but yeah definitely I guess
the time pressure might be the biggest
factor for black thumb like you were
saying it's deciding between all these
different options with with only the 11
minutes on the clock
well I'm sure he's looking for a
knockout blow right now you know there's
not always one there though and that's
that's sometimes the problem yeah so we
can actually check on the C group then
still kind of cooks up kind of heats up
our pairings in the C group our
christian shrila playing against al
Shawn Marathi Abadi and arum jacobian
playing ants archers Naik sons and our
key matchup of the day Group C leader
Brandon Jacobsen playing Dmitry
Gordievsky and he actually has the white
pieces again that's something I didn't
realize this Jade Seah
to whites in a row to start the
tournament right and he is very good
with both yesterday and today I feel
like he's playing great
yes you know actually I thought you had
the quote of the day after we after we
did our broadcast you know yes so we on
the on the interview yesterday I Brandon
told me something I didn't realize the
guy is I knew he was fifteen I didn't
understand that he's already going to
Columbia yeah it's it's a lot and so
Caleb was like oh man just go off and
solve cancer cure diseases of the you
have no business do it you know what are
you doing
he is playing beautiful chess here i wor
see it I would say white is better in
this position and and I just want to
back up to demonstrate some of the
skills this Bishop b5 Sicilian we're
seeing a lot of both before the World
Championship and now after with Bobby
and Carlsen playing this position now
you can take on c6 you can Castle we do
this line here Bobby by the way in this
position played be four against Carlsen
and you know in that game I really was
thinking that Bobby had him the Carlsen
just call me dealt with that anyways
takes table memories we're gonna go
position and here
Gordievsky plays this is where like
we're GM stuff is interesting so
Gordievsky plays Queen c7 and just about
everyone else in this position played
Queen ISA does it make a big difference
maybe the Queen on e7 let's just put
this here has more scope later to the
King side even though it doesn't feel
like it's important now also scope to
the Queen side we'll talk about why that
might be important and I'm
see seven also maybe taking away away a
square for the night to do a little
dance to d4 interesting so anyways
that's why I think my is my layman's
understanding of why queen e7 is more
popular than what Gordievsky played
Queen c7 okay so let's look they should
be three b6 h3 night of 692 let me just
say a couple basic things is this simple
setup where white is putting his pawns
and the light squares and has this
beautiful bishop here right so the idea
is even though he doesn't have a light
square bishop he's gonna use his pawns
to fight for the lights woods castles
and here there are two my understanding
really two plans for white one is a 3
and B 4 and the other is as in the game
with a 4 and there are two totally
different plans a 3 B 4 really aims to
open it up on the Queen side and a 4 is
trying to get this positional squeeze
that we're gonna get in the game where
the knight sits on c4 b 6 has to be
babysat and we're going to slowly do
this I don't even know let's call it
pressure on the inside it's not
necessarily an attack right and I feel
like Brandon really helped you played
this next phase well watch what he does
maybe this is one upside to Queen c7
those you do have b6 defended for the
moment at least but Bishop h6 and now
you know so we're gonna we're tickling
the King a little bit 9h - mm-hmm that's
a nice nice 4 and now black sadly gives
away his pride
the unopposed light square bishop and in
general I feel like the dynamic of these
positions and we get a lot of them these
days well both with especially with this
opening and also in the Berlin with Jana
pose bishop as and then the compensation
for white is the messed up part the seed
points so black gives that up and let's
just talk about this position for a
second black is worse because the bishop
is bad and the knight is worse - so it's
like white doesn't have like a winning
position right he has to better minor
pieces and watch what he does Knight f6
you could we're not gonna take it and
let the bishop out no we're just gonna
ask the knight what it wants
and unfortunately for Gordievsky i think
he chose you know if you if you're a
fighter you don't want to just say to
yourself okay now I'm worse because
that's what would happen if you did that
so instead you play Knight h5 and now
you have now the knight is terrible yeah
well went from being battling d7 about
on h5 but all right was it a step up in
the world it's the question no no the
knight is terrible yeah so this is
suffering it's not you know this is a
real massage position I'm sure that
we're gonna still see it in the game
that's a massage position and Jacobsen
doesn't even have that much time so but
let's go through it f6 Bishop e3 rook da
Queen e2 Bishop g7 you can feel it it's
like the black pieces need a lot before
they get back into having a job in life
rook 81 and black trades all the rooks
off now some of the maybe c3 we could
criticize but in general white is
holding the advantage that he had bishop
f8 king f7 and I'm sure one reason
Jacobson has spent so much time here is
that he is
trying to find some kind of way through
before black manages to do things like
Knight g7 and back even notice even if
he gets the Knight d6 it's still not
great the knight could also maybe dream
about 98 of d6 in general the knight
needs to fix himself right yeah it needs
to fix himself so as white do you look
for pawn breaks here do you look for
stuff like an eventual f4 or like an h4
h5 or do you try to focus on peace
placed oh well we're looking for
massaging the guy okay and unfortunately
with Queen f3 it doesn't feel right
because you the Queen was doing
something on d1 mm and you're not really
threatening anything unless I'm missing
something here you know you're not
threatening anything yet you are
preventing the knight from coming back
but you're not threatening anything so I
still like Brandon's position he sent
some nice time trouble though yeah five
minutes is not a lot for 13 moves and
more than anything else I getting the
feeling I'm getting the feeling that
he's even though he knows he's better
he's uncomfortable with knowing exactly
what to do here
and we've all been there yes but nervous
feeling where it's like hmm is have
things started going going a different
way than I than I wanted but yes they're
still positive but yeah he needs to find
a plan and he doesn't really have kind
of like that the clock is ticking right
you know like I just found found a way
to kind of regroup and so if Brandon's
not careful I think just this 97 96 like
you're talking about and it's kind of
back in the game well while that game
continues I did want to mention we have
a couple new results over in the B group
actually Sam 7 has drawn his game
against her Gauri Oberon as well as in
the C group Christian Chawla has drawn
Elgin morontia body so two more draws
today right so so far so peaceful but I
think I saw in the YouTube chat that one
of our other games was actually he
up quite a bit well there's a lot of
games that are heating it yeah so let's
check in on the Howell game because we
were talking about that earlier let's
see what happens I'm Queen c2 Bishop a3
happens and I think the reason is you'd
like to play rook a3 but maybe you got
to worry about 9 c4 and here my
intuition was Bishop before first but we
can do it later after with b7 as well in
fact this makes sense where the we're
gonna we're gonna tag the rook on a8 for
a tempo and then probably come back to
e4 so a very simple dynamic that might
look peaceful if I look peaceful but
basically White has to generate play
against the black king or else this is
the famous or else because the pawn will
come and yeah it's gonna be this is not
as peaceful as it looks
the white king is simply better and
moves he can throw the H pawn up later
as well so yeah I don't know this is the
type of position I would get very
nervous with with the white pieces even
if it's objectively ok for them I would
always prefer to be on the side with
that you know kind of sense of
inevitability right whose side has a
sense of inevitable
you know the see pawns not going
anywhere and unless something happens
square by square that poems gonna get
down the board I think that's that's my
sense of the position but yeah I think
it's double edge but I I guess I would
rather be white fair you know the thing
to is then even though everybody likes
to to bishops rook b7 let's just play
we're going to assume Bishop takes
everybody likes the two bishops but this
night is going to be a real jerk because
when it come if any kind of weakness
happens on the kingside like your f5
move then he's gonna start bouncing
around and he already is looking at this
d4 square so yeah I know intuitively I'm
gonna say this I think black would like
an exchange of rows because that will
make the chances for white mating you
less by you I mean black I agreed some
of my is it seems easier to push that
pawn for it if if the rooks do get off
the board and I think that's why black
cleaver of d8 here it was trying to keep
that night from going too far or if it
does want to go somewhere you have to
allow this this or trade so this is a
really interesting position we got this
is definitely time pressure and one of
the nice things I don't have too nicely
about time pressure is you know the
people at this level can play very great
moves for a series of moves but then
when you get here and both sides are
coming around ten minutes you know just
my experience I'll say there's gonna be
a lot of mistakes play especially with
so much so many moves to be to be played
right they need to know if there's 1314
moves in this position so I would say
intuitively rook a one followed by
moving the knight or Bishop to e4 is
kind of what's looking at you could
consider other things though like rook
e1 you could consider Bishop before and
you could consider the rook trade but
yeah I don't like it I don't like it
but even then I really don't well I was
about to say white shouldn't worry too
much but you don't don't trade the Rose
well before this games get too crazy and
time pressure I did actually want to
take a quick look at the prize funds for
this event so that's something we
haven't done yet and so there's actually
quite a bit at stake here a first place
in the a group is playing for $12,000
with a total prize fund of $40,000 and
over in the B group we have a
first-place prize of $6,000 total price
one of 21,000 and in the C group we have
a first-place prize of $4,000 the total
prize fund of $14,000
and this is actually double in most
cases what the classic series normally
has so it's nice to see the the money
behind these tournaments kind of growing
a bit although of course a lot of these
players are just here for the chess you
know want to improve their game want to
get some more experience alright let's
look at the Shanklin game alright over
the same Shanklin so you know Shanklin
lost yesterday probably over press
definitely over pressed but beautiful
game by Howell and Shanklin came out
fighting and I will say this I copied
Shanklin recently I had a game against
GM Sergey Ehrenberg and I saw that
Shanklin came up with a system here this
system that he played and I liked it a
lot for black is Shanklin special is the
Shanklin special you know he doesn't
always play the French so I'm gonna
guess that he saw the Gawain played this
variation is white and said okay let's
go forth you can also play Bishop d6
here but he goes Queen c7 and we get
this position this was all played fairly
quickly and so Sam definitely had the
advantage of who is better prepared now
they're thinking in this position there
they were thinking I was up there
watching and this is a nice just a nice
French position because the pressure of
the C pawn combined with the pressure on
the e pawn is gonna make it hard for
white to achieve his dreams of mating
you on on the Kings side and of course
you have to worry about various f5s and
if you take on g6 we're probably gonna
take back with the F pawn hmm so c4
snip-snip
this position looks like it shouldn't be
that scary for white but the problem is
and this happens a lot when you play
against the French is that you're a pawn
is just a weakness whereas you could
argue about the C pawn but the e pawn
here is a little bit easier for white
black to get to especially with that fat
rook on d5 and something I always wonder
about in positions like these are the
drawbacks to getting a move like f4 in
if if y could achieve it is that
something white actually wants to do or
is that kind of to weakening in a lot of
cases that's in the position in general
though you know it's clear that and you
can see there's with move h4 is that the
the virtue of the pawn on e5 is that
white gains space on the Queen side and
by virtue of that space he's allowed to
make some weaknesses with moves like h4
but unfortunately when you've traded off
some you don't really have that much
juice here and Baidu's I just mean
attacking potential would to throw on
the fire against the black King and now
you know I like Sam's position a lot
we've got the D file and we've got the
weakness and watch what he does
rook see for Queen b6 knight c6 what is
he going for we're looking for the
octopus over here all right
rook c5 Knight e4 Knight d3 rook takes
rook takes beautiful pawn sacrifice
assume we're going to get it back but
it's a beautiful pawn sacrifice and
white played rook c2 and go angel one of
the reasons I wanted to look at this is
go wanes under an immense amount of time
pressure and black definitely with a
nice position and a variety of moves
that he can now play he can play let's
just say the obvious he can play ninety
five and night b2 but that's his octopus
so you don't want to touch that night
right you've worked hard to get it to
deep three and it's almost perfectly
placed but let's say that both of those
are very pleasant for
even 95 because then it's your the one
on the attack and that pawn on h5 will
probably go as well so 95 is very
pleasant 92 might even be playable I
guess I would worry that some kind of
Queen b3 is gonna exchange the Queen's
but even there you know like like still
coming back to d3 whenever you want so
and the other thing in addition to those
two moves is I'm sure Sam is also
looking to see if he doesn't have some
kind of strengthening move because
White's not really threatening anything
now yeah of course you know Knights
always need squares black's knight is
found one and I'm not sure that White's
Knight is going to going to have
anywhere nice to sit on in the near
future well he's sitting where he's
gonna sit so one thing I just want to
say I admire about Sam is you know he
lost a rough game yesterday and it went
after we stopped the broadcast we said
that he was in big trouble and probably
losing but that thing it ended up going
along and he's didn't follow the ancient
Russian instructions to try to get a
draw the next round
he's clearly came out you know lost a
one English guy it's going after the
next and he's thinking hard on it he
knows it's a pleasant position one thing
to you know I've known Sam since was a
kid and one thing I'm interested in the
way he's improved his chess is that my
to my understanding anyway he's really
focused on calculation and so if you can
calculate deeply in a position like this
especially when your opponent's got
three minutes it's a really important
advantage whereas I I could imagine just
playing a move like 95 on let's call it
principle or intuition
definitely um with that in mind do we
want to take a look at the last game in
Group A sure
Jeffrey Zhang against Liam Leigh sure
alright so here we have Jeffrey Zhang
and this is actually looks like one of
the the craziest games of the day I have
no idea what's going on here but blacks
King is sitting out on f6 with no cover
whatsoever a little bit frightening if I
were Liam lay here well and we should
also say that Jeffrey is again he
doesn't care about his King just left on
left it on e1 for the day yeah this was
a very bizarre opening I'll show it to
you guys so we get this business and
okay knight c6 it's a little weird black
intends Oh 97 so okay this all happens
a5 is a little weird a4 okay
now in an old-school way you'd say Oh
whites gonna play c4 well no and then c6
I'm gonna say I also didn't entirely
understand 94 takes it now this is a
real mystery move to me I really didn't
get it I really didn't get it with
bishop g3 which is like encouraging
black to play Knight f5 it in general
just on a superficial glance it looks to
me like black that white is better in
this position the unopposed bishop seems
strong the pawn Center pawn seemed nice
so I didn't get this move it I I don't
understand it either but okay Bishop b2
and now g6 apparently with notions of
playing h5h for now some humans would
Castle here Bishop f4 instead g5 we
start this little game like in this
kingi seven here we come it looks very
nice for what year this looks very nice
by the way you know Jeffrey is playing
so many different openings now it's kind
of my colleague debate I think he's just
realized that he's a good chess player
and it almost doesn't matter how he gets
there in the end so you know it's it's
all chess - Jeffrey but this is
obviously great hit with a six queen c5
and he's allowing him to come take on g3
Tamas all right check to the misérable
queen check to the miserable King let's
check to the king and I mean this looks
the I black must be lost right well
probably but it's kind of a question is
is the White Queen gonna get sidelined
my question was can you play I guess
rook beef I guess you can't play rugby
five because there's a queen g3 check
all right wanted to take advantage of
that that's C Ponton let's play the new
variation okay let's say let's say let's
say we just move the Queen and then it
still is
maybe c5 but you know some five you're
opening this diagnose of the king - so
he's clearly looking for something
better than Queen before but let's just
say that on Queen before it looks like
white should be better if not we're just
with you guys wanting to find the art
our king is gonna be snug on d2 this guy
can come cruise over here this guy's
already doing a job it just it looks
like it's all falling it looks really
bad so there was some moves in there
that maybe we'll get even a chance to
talk to my didn't mm-hmm they were
beyond me Bishop g3 is a lot it's a lot
to take in
yes so it's really interested yeah that
this is a kind of thing by the way I
just want to say on a personal note that
the whole commentating gig it's like
this is what to me it's the most
interesting as I get a chance to be like
hey Jeffrey buddy what was that going on
there
explain that move to me and you know
also if you guys have questions that you
want to ask the people especially if we
know they're coming in absolutely then
go ahead and ask yeah we've got an eye
on the YouTube chat pulled up here Queen
before was played and now I love this
watching this the dimensionality of
being able to watch them sweat
especially as we get closer to the
dreaded time control well yeah I mean
we're in he's in time pressure both of
them are time pressure but this you know
very unpleasant situation and I don't I
don't know I don't know if I've ever
seen so much space around a black king
he's almost got like a whole two four by
four square of just nothing around the
king and his light square bishop doesn't
help him that much for defending his
situation definitely not so what do you
what do you try is as black here do you
try Queen takes g3 and hope the Queen
can be a nice defender maybe but then
you're gonna owe me a tempo with your
rook once you take on g3 that is that's
very true I would say they don't owe you
a lot of things here that in general if
the white king can safely sit on D -
without counter play black will get made
it there's no question about that so he
needs to find some way to avoid getting
to get counter play and you know
obviously it's gonna it's a tall order
it is it's tough to suggest news for
black here you know I'm I'm guessing
he's gonna play c5 just because if the
black if the white king gets to d2 it
just hard to imagine he plays rook f5
let's take a look
that's not updated but I can update it
rook f5 and okay so we can that's
probably a better version that when I
was talking about because now on King D
2 then I can play C 5 and also I can
play Queen G 3 without getting smacked
with the Queen a5 tempo doesn't look
like this route can stay on f5 though
what if I were to play g4 here I think
Wayne has a lot of it yeah g4 is
definitely a possibility I'd like to
keep suggesting moves for the white
player you can take the black I'm
assuming his intention is something like
Queen g3 rook F - yeah but it doesn't
look good
think you're preaching to the choir but
there it goes g4 and yeah this game
looks like it's but I mean black needs
some miracle business here I guess I
don't besides Queen g3 I honestly what I
don't see much else perm
yeah it's kind of what the other brutal
things about this g4 move is white just
brought another attacking force into the
fray there yeah the the pawn is no joke
let's see if we can somehow survive for
blacks so Queen g3 mm-hmm pinky gain d2
now this this doesn't look right but I'm
going to do it I want to throw at c5 oh
it's just so it's so miserable
okay I did it though c5 I just have to I
just have Queen b6 and then I can take
the rook eventually well problem is 28
you see I just want to guess if I don't
get c5 in though I know I have to maybe
and so the dream is him doing this
there's more if you just wanted to be
simple about things though you could
just do that yeah but that was that was
my game plan at least okay let's let's
just try it out though because maybe
it's not that easy snip snap it and
we're gonna put it somewhere just put it
on that score that's it Queen g3 king
detail on the board
so probably just Quincy 5 here right and
and then rock f2 so we at least
predicted that many things why yeah why
can I think white is a nice choice here
I'm I'm guessing there might be
something violent here because okay but
I guess one question is how big of a
threat is rookie to so and we actually
just see rock f1 actually he just was
playing very simply very quickly I think
that's that's probably a good plan with
with the time situation on the clock you
know you should be winning and you know
it's definitely gonna be winning if you
play it simply so why why allow for
things like Ricky to when you can just
not calculate and play play good chess
moves yeah well here's an idea
nope that's not that's a bad idea I've
decided I thought for a second I might
get away with Bishop takes g4 but there
is still just throw it takes enough to
newark f1 so that looks grim i think
some version of King g7 King g6 either
before or after taking on f1 it's how
over is it probably totally over but
white still needs to find you know
something keep King g7 was played so
it's gonna be similar mm-hmm
rook f1
and Jeffrey to play now actually that
move struck me as odd because cantina
bring the lady in with rook F to Queen F
to Lane d6 it doesn't look this I
thought that was kind of like the whole
ideas yet and maybe Queen there to keep
the lady out maybe he plays Queen f7
there I'm about to see it so yeah we
have Queen f2 on the board
mm-hmm maybe Queen f7 for black eye I
don't know what else to try besides just
cuddling cuddling around my kid yeah and
and let's just say the problem is that
the King is exposed and the White King
has totally snug so everything is going
to lose that Queen f7 if you wanted to
be calm about life you could play g5 for
example right there's no rush that's
tough yeah beautiful King position so I
just I didn't want to mention it looks
like the game in Group B the last game
remaining with the Ruby leader Ganguly
has actually simplified quite a bit into
let's take a lady a winning endgame so
let's look at where we left off we had
rook takes a6
Queen B 294 Knight f5
oh that is a very nice move look at that
move Knight f5 yeah just uh saying that
Bishop on f3 is untouchable because
British exceeds me maybe let's show that
so if Knight f5 and Bishop c3 ouch or
and also similarly if Knight thief
Knight f3 Bishop c3 ouch
okay so that was a very nice tactic and
Bishop f5 is a real concession and now
he says okay this looks to me like two
bishops and weaknesses and and appoint
and pawns you got the material you've
got the better pieces you've got the
better structure and I think you're
winning another what else is left
maybe you can't take on d4 okay depends
where the night goes I guess but
honestly I think the pawn will
eventually fall for example I don't know
Knight c5 I don't know which which one
appeals to most I guess I'll go to c5
then something maybe like f4 could be
play first I don't like that I don't
like that at all for a white I can apply
king c3 and just yeah really try to take
your d7 pawn get something for my
trouble so
I think about it
let you know yeah this is terrible like
d6 yeah that thought move gave me some
some trepidation I guess I'll play
Knight d7 and try to attack your king
with my only two remaining pieces yeah
there's so much bummer here like black
has so many different moves he did check
first
but like Bishop c6 even oh man
that might be a winner yeah I mean I
think this is for the winner well let's
look at what happened will at least take
it to the time control rook before
there's rook c8 and then Knight c5
so let's just show that the tactic is
that if here here I was thinking I might
have a problem maybe white shouldn't
have gone for this low because can you
take and play Rick see for and how was
that how was that recommend getting look
there's 96 it's 96 check oh no all right
no it's a were see thought they are
gonna think a little bit because they
just reached oh wait a second yeah Black
has one more move
let's white wait till he gets this move
he's got one minute left for 40 and
wants to do it right so the the drama is
the whites hope is that on d6 the night
will squirrel its way in to like 97 so
he says know what you know what I'm just
gonna play Bishop c6 and stop any
business and surely you expect a win for
black here though but there's just a d4
is weak f2 is weak h4 is weak I can
kinda I can almost imagine just black
playing rugby one and then Rick h1 and
then Rick takes h4 and then kind of just
saying what can you do about it right no
you're right it should be left there's
more weaknesses for white to his only
hope is to get some kind of counter play
with the night into f6 or somewhere yeah
maybe or F for the night could dream
about going to f4 maybe that's the dream
that you should pursue it seems seems
like it might be a bit slow
well is this problem of the cliff or
what do you want him to do well that's
like you have to play king c3 or III I
guess and I just wanna play your FB one
[Laughter]
well and I was to say that was a
beautiful
you know the whole this whole thing from
ganguly really beautiful play and maybe
we'll get him ight be able to talk to
him a little later too about his yeah I
felt from the beginning very nice play a
pretty pretty nice game for the GUI
let's look at Brandon's game yeah I
think he's he's actually below a minute
now with five moves to play so I wonder
about these kids too because they might
not need any time yes you know he thinks
just for just just to you know make sure
but he has the ideas immediately so
alright Bishop d6 this is where we left
off
h4 there's mythic so black is saying I'm
just gonna hang out I've done all I need
to do oh wait so I can do a similar
trick I think that's wise for black get
the King to the other side I don't know
how I feel about that I don't know I
feel about that maybe maybe he thinks g4
isn't the square not the square for him
okay I don't know where he's what was
the idea I don't know I I would think
wait what is the nighttime it's going D
to is it going to d3 maybe does he want
to play something like
p4 honestly if you were in this position
once you say to yourself oh I think the
knight on g4 would be a good score oh
well maybe this not on d3 is is an idea
okay it did happen this night on d3 also
let Sun this is
position I feel like yeah he's lost most
of his advantage you're unfortunately
why because he gave the black pieces
enough time to find themselves you need
time to find yourself somebody went on
their journey of self-discovery and they
came back better for it that's right
okay let's take a look were kind of you
know by the way if we can get Ganguly in
here after he wins maybe it won't even
happen that fast but if you can get I
would love to they might see him they
might take some time let's look at Sam's
game because he did take Ani fine see
this was our moment and this is oh yeah
poor Gawain is really gone in time snip
snip snip g4 is a sad move to make and
I'll just say it
dogmatically or yeah being a dog with
this this they have the general thing
about these positions is that the heavy
endgame the situation of the king is
like the most paramount thing especially
in a practical level so the white is
trying to actually say something like
you know what I will eventually get
counterplay because of the light squares
some kind of dirty check but of course
you know this should be listen something
black should be able to deal with even
by playing g6 if he has to so the Queen
threatens to come in this looks very
pleasant yeah moving a kata to no safety
there will never be safety again for the
white king no blacks to play some good
moves I'm sure he's thinking about
something like f5 and he's also gonna
try to you know not blitz going in the
time pressure but put some really nasty
curveball onto a move right now
he won't be able to respond especially
before that extra 30 minutes comes in it
can be a that's definitely when you want
to pose the the biggest questions I
think I mean f5 is the real natural way
to just try to hit the guy mm-hmm but
I'm sure there's other things too
well there's there might be maybe some
doubt in Sam's mind after the events of
yesterday of playing something like f5
kind of so quickly in such a crucial
moment now heavy does he might might be
thinking about it yeah he'd ever I
studied with that kid when he was a kid
he never feared anything that was part
of his problem okay let's take a look at
Howells game it's looking better for
black now I think that the c-pawn
inevitability the inevitability cared of
it tonight every he takes traineeships
bishop which his king should feel a
reasonable about it was this trade force
soon yeah I don't know if I I like Queen
d5
well I I think he's trying to say he's
worried hmm
so I think he is well there's a question
mark is he who's playing for the win so
let's see 94
can i I can't
I wanted to own it to take it and feel
no really good about my c-pawn but it
does not quite work so can I just push
my pawn then c3 you've got to be careful
because you're not threatening anything
and King f1 King e2 is coming well no I
ain't threatening to take the knife yeah
okay but I mean like I can do rook b8 c
8 and then you got to worry about my
king come sure but okay you know the
definitely c3 is a candidate hmm it's
honestly hard for black to come up with
a different idea in c3
like I yeah I can agree this Bishop c5
just touch the night let's see what it
wants and I'm Bishop c5 you might want
to worry about rugby five there's
there's I guess there's some awkwardness
here for black let's try your c3 move
okay and obviously if I get it for to
just been played it's just been playing
nice so I think objectively this should
be a drop but this is like this is such
a tense situation that both players can
make mistakes and definitely blunder so
for example if you say check to them as
a bouquet and then you come here and
then you do this you need an answer to
Bishop c5 well I shouldn't say
necessarily you need an answer because
really black is just threatening to bail
out what they should be for right like
maybe maybe that's how this game ends
that might be how it ends but white is
gonna well yeah it's not gonna be think
about it too long what did he ruk ruk ba
da was played yeah we're gonna assume
king f7 that happened
and now look he said check to the
miserable King here maybe that's how
this game will end the thing about check
to the miserable King there is there
might be some kind of I doubt it but
there might be some way to do a 96 trick
so the black King definitely wants to
think about what's happening maybe that
is a little tricky I guess you don't
want to play Bishop e7 because of Rick
c7 and you don't really want to play
King g6 or King g8 because of 96 I guess
maybe I'll just show a variation that
just roughly what what one fear for
black could be is that in this position
if I'm black I'm worried that my pawn is
going to get eaten it's still a long way
to go but it like yeah that's one of the
concerns I would have if I was black
alright so check that the miserable King
happens he to go went to g6 this mode
for a second here
rook c7 was played no 96 then I wonder
what
well no 96 the pawn is running oh that's
a good yeah that's my point to it so I
think Bishop c5 is our main move now was
it helpful that we yeah we checked the
King away we didn't want the King to
come up later so that made sense and
the nice thing for white is on Bishop c5
we at least have a draw because blacks
not threatening he's threatening just to
equalize I still think rook c5 is
dangerous hmm
because snip-snip a knight c2 and if
King f5 I have f3 ah so that's how you
keep the keep the King out well I I
guess you know that's one of those ones
you really have to calculate calculate
it all out this is f3 and then g5 and
then they're trying to figure it out now
and it's still it's tough it's 40
seconds
but yeah Bishop c5 is the right human
move to play especially in time pressure
and white meats if you want white wants
to win he needs some kind of genius move
here on King f1 I'm assuming we'll just
liquidate to a draw does he have
anything any genius level play
well let's see he's got the zoom players
looking a little testy but I like this
stuff the board looks like there's a
yellow tint but I I want to assure
people there's not actually a yellow
tint it's your standard chess board I
don't I don't really see what white can
do about this I would expect just
something like King f1 and I'm just
accepting accepting the draw but if
you're gonna do something now now is the
time any fancy trick here exciting to
hear the jaws theme in the backgrounds
like make a move before it's too late
oh man here comes hey bloody move you
see move oh my god yeah there goes how
cool calm collected two seconds on the
clock King f1 I should play that's
that's essentially a draw for I think
after Bishop D for the game the games
pretty well over and I there's
definitely no way for black to continue
on do you think okay so we're gonna call
that a draw let's look at the Sam game
some stuff definitely happen I'm not
sure Sam it's too happy about it we're
gonna see here so is looking where did
we leave is rook g5 this all happened
this looked great and I wanted f5 and
instead Sam said you know what I'll do
well actually this Oh and actually
breaking news we have Geoffrey who I
believe just defeated Liam Lee so maybe
he's gonna come on in
yeah we can get him down in the studio
to talk about his game that's quite the
attacking game a few strange poops like
Bishop g3 that are maybe above our heads
that's a hopefully it is it is awesome
that pretty soon and while he's coming
I'll just say with this Shanklin game
yeah
Wayne made time control and the problem
for Shanklin is do you have anything
here because I when the f7 pawn this
it's really hard to avoid perpetual
checks with g6 and ei still still about
the King's safety even with just the
Queen's right and let's just say this
has been White's intention all along by
keeping that punim h5 it's really a
drawing idea at this point if we get
salmon I'm gonna ask him me in this
position buddy
why did you play like riff d2 is winning
even he is winning a pawn so that one
was true but then I'm Queen c7 he needs
something special he might be able to I
mean he's obviously looking for
something special but I don't know quite
what it is it's it's quite difficult to
find maybe he wants to I was just gonna
say take on a2 and then try to grab that
that long b12 h7 diagonal and start the
perpetual is that way but all your pawns
are just just falling well the e6 Palmer
can write that honestly it might be
something he thinks about in the this so
it went snip-snip
and then Shanklin i guess what is the
draw draw for right were they fine ah
yeah that's that's it that's it for this
game so that's actually that was last
game in the group a section here so that
leaves us with Geoffrey Zhang winning
his game against Liam Lee David hell
drawing his game against switz and then
we fully expect white to uh to go for
the draw here after Queen g6 and Queen
e8 just a simple simple perpetual and
while we're well waiting for Geoffrey to
come down let's just take a quick look
at this ganguly game we're expecting
black to win this thing
Caleb's method was to brutally go for
repeat one rook h1 page for taking the
long way around and seems it seems okay
to me there might be other tricks
obviously you can throw an F for right
now as well
it's almost seems why not why not play
f4 yeah and I guess after king day 3 a
big relevant point is now the d3 squares
is occupied so the knight can't come
through it through the d3 square to some
place like f4 where it would like to be
and the bummer is though even if we do
it this way and the night comes the
night then I assume white is dreaming
about it doesn't seem like it's ever
gonna be enough it's it's some a very
ambitious dream taking a deep on here I
don't think I could I do
I mean he is obviously has to drink you
got a dream and we it's official now Sam
Franklin has drawn his game I can start
going Jones and maybe we will get Sam
down in the studio after Jeffery then
they find that yep I was gonna say that
could be a dream here with d5 here at
least you're fighting for something yeah
of course there's there's those famous
F&H po american games where they're
somehow miraculously d it's more like
the knight wants to dream about somehow
touching that guy it's it's a ways off
but at least we're doing something now
f4 west plate that makes a lot more
sense
so f4 check king d3 you do this just
looks completely over it's not nice it's
not nice what's happening so let's just
summarize what we think is gonna have
them gank at least gonna go up - oh yeah
yeah Ghoulies gonna go up - oh
incredibly and how will drew his game so
that would be he'll be +1 and Geoffrey
will be +1 mm-hmm and then we're still
owe you a haven't talked about Brandon
in a long time let's go
Oh while we're waiting for Geoffrey
let's look at Brandon his game continues
that this game continues on and so he
did actually launched that H pawn up the
boards so this is this is hit his idea I
guess to kind of probe is at some point
maybe taking on g6 and trying to I have
to say this night f8 what is the deal
oh he wants to play Knight d7 to f6 or
something mmm I guess so anything it
still happened
wait a second wait a second
so Knight of fate we're threatening this
pawn Oh
let's assume b3 comes
what's the next move you can alpha0 him
with h6 aha the classic just take all
your space and then say I have more
space and win the game somehow so that
third part that I never really quite
good it's winning the game somehow well
I met with alpha zero is like the the
computer and a lot of weird positions
played age six and no one understood why
yeah there was an interesting line that
I was shown in the caro-kann that alpha
zero likes to play where it plays a four
and then it plays a five and then it
plays a six and it's on move like nine
but it does like that the rook pawn the
rook on space so yeah this game is still
going on there's one other game actually
in the C group I don't believe we've
taken a look at it we haven't looked at
it at all
Oh Cobian and nine songs the last
tournament I covered here in st. Louis
Cobian one was I guess was the B section
and this position I think we have to say
he's definitely got a pleasant little
end game nudge let's call it an endgame
nudge with the more active pieces so the
nice knight on d5 and so much space on
the Queen side that c7 doesn't really
feel so comfortable oh where it's at
right and blacks just gonna make a claim
that the g4 Knight will save him the end
let's just say the obvious bummer is
that this square is the blockade square
in the Knights covering it for a nice
covering but it's not so clear like
with what do you do next how do you how
do you coordinate the rooks I guess a
dream would be rook d3 something like
that even then you got to worry about
night eh - but something like that to
activate the rooks maybe trying to plan
- I work on the f5 squares like I've
takes G yeah I think she may be king you
two first and then rook at five eyeing
that age punt would be would be my go-to
plan here I think
and in general white should keep the
tension as long as he can yeah so King
you to first and then uh make some
decisions
it's very concrete because black just
committed with g6 so clearly he's saying
that he wants this tension so presumably
what he's gonna do if he takes on f fine
well I like the looks of this opening of
the F file
yeah we play King you to here I guess
thinking you too
something like that
age six maybe yeah well I'll let you
continue taking a look at this I believe
Jeffrey's never need to come in cool so
I will go ahead and bow out here for a
moment
well we get Jeffrey Zhong in the studio
this was a game I really you know I
maybe didn't spend as much time as I
wanted to on this game but it was
alright I'm gonna drink some of your
water too by the way
so chest fans I didn't understand this
game mm-hmm
send in your questions maybe we'll get
them
we'll get them up here for Jeffrey so we
have Jeffrey in the studio and the first
thing I want to say to Jeffrey is while
we're getting set up sometimes I feel
like I understand what's going on in
this game I didn't have any
understanding of what was going on so
well where would where should we begin I
guess we just go from the start okay so
night of three this is the new new kind
of thing I guess and tell us about this
approach yeah [ __ ] before it's not the
most popular approach but it's
definitely been played at a high level
and yeah the idea is kind of you put
some pressure on this c7 pond so maybe
more normal Bishop g5 lines and yeah
just kind of a different way to play
them than usual okay okay yes sir I
think 96 was a little bit a little weird
right yeah it was a little weird for me
generally because sometimes white plays
Queen a4 check that's also a line to
write to provoke it
I thought the same thing I was like
what's going on but he wants to play 97
I know I think he said his idea was 94
but maybe mix the new board because
there's a very serious line that goes 94
so in this position yeah 94 rook c1 g5
let's say Bishop e3 and now nice or
sorry they usually they usually take on
c3 so after Bishop e3 yeah
takes and then knight c6 maybe was
trying to reach something like this yeah
and this is quite that's complicated
yeah but in the game it seemed like I
got a pleasant position so right so it's
one cuz yeah usually one day Castle they
they're putting the pawn on see
which maybe looks more more natural than
the night okay he goes 97 now Queen b3 I
liked my deal or any was if he takes us
III I I would take with the pawn uh-huh
and play for quick c4 and you just want
to Bishop d6 trade if he goes back
Bishop d6 here I think is not possible
because I can take an eye to be fine no
you can't even do it right what a bummer
yeah well or you can even do it he could
think about on the next move actually a5
a3 he could think about Bishop d6 the
point is if I take and Knight be five
years Queen b6 but after Bishop d6 I
think Bishop g5 is good for me but even
that very eat that well I guess there's
a room take c7 at the end of that yeah
but Rick's 7/8 e6 of the the rook might
really Mike Harris yeah but it might
just be there forever
[Laughter]
okay so he sniped and you know it's
funny when you introduced this position
because I felt like this kind of light
square stuff was what he was after right
when he went for this position right and
then planted everything on the leg
squares now here's where okay here's
where yeah we're gonna ask you some
questions so I feel like most humans
would have played moves like Bishop e2
or c4
yeah well first c4 I thought was risky
because c4 c5 I thought it was maybe his
idea alright I wasn't 100% about it
maybe I can get away but it seemed
unnecessary to allow the
complications so he once quit n5 check I
see
uh-huh yeah I wasn't sure okay so 92 is
we're just gonna get rid of this guy
first yeah exactly I wanted to get rid
of
I thought about Bishop d3 that was the
move that I would strongly consider huh
and the problem with Bishop d3 is I
think there's a smooth v6 very annoying
moved and he just wants a [ __ ] six
neck so I felt maybe I'm not really
getting rid of this night after all
because if I take it now it's there
could be some risks on the diagonal sure
okay
again playing on the black trying to
plan the lights yes okay so okay here's
here's what I really didn't get it so
what is c6 about well I mean he wants to
he wants to make it so that this pawn
will not be hanging in some lines but I
will say I expected something concrete
maybe not g6 and sick concrete right
Bishop g35 yes something vile he needs
to do something violent before your
before I just push me to even some weird
move like Knight h4 I don't know fair
enough yeah right nice where I wasn't
worried about because I thought I could
always simplify for example if you go
night h4 okay I thought okay first of
all I'm not in any rush sure sure sure
yeah and I'm just saying like heat but
well let's put it this way you've got to
do something because White has the
long-term trend with this beautiful
Bishop right yeah and also I like my
pawn shop from Queen said I feel like
these seven can be a four okay so at
least okay at least we agree I
understand where you're coming from on
that one now I want to really ask you
though about that move yeah okay c4 is
the obvious move and it was actually
correct okay but I was afraid of
again 96 Bishop g3 i-5 and
he wants yeah he just wants to blast it
with f4 and it might be still be good
for me but I didn't really want to go
into because okay I would like to play
c5 here uh-huh
the idea is if he goes f4 now I will
throw in a check on c4 kh8 let's take
with a pawn for example Knight takes
takes takes takes and castle and this
vision should be very good for me but
you were worried about bishop Issa I was
worried about Bishop e6 yes I was
worried about Bishop e6 and now it
wasn't as clear because let's say Bishop
d6 very obvious move mm-hmm he goes rook
f7 and the point is let's say I make a
random of Bishop e2 very logical okay
the point is he has this move d5 and now
he doesn't have this backward pawn any
more on b7 and once he puts Bishop on d5
it's actually very hard to see what what
I'm trying to do and he might already be
better so that's kind of some some lines
that concern me okay yeah I think yeah
if we got this this would definitely
wouldn't have been nice for me so that's
why yeah I wasn't sure if okay okay so
so this is like a prophylactic move yes
yes and if he goes f5 now we're okay
first if you goes nine g6
okay let's look now that is h4 and right
you fight anything to deal with okay all
right I'm coming around so you're
teaching me here that's deep
because it feels weird because it feels
like oh you're inviting NIDA
yes I'm not actually sure that it was a
good move but I just explained
right right okay and if I thought I
think maybe I also go age for I wasn't
sure so just just so the chest fans get
the ight some of the ideas in on f-fine
I might also play H for just make sure
this bishop stays alive did you know
about floor okay I'll play devil's
advocate might be fine yes okay
so ideas if I go see for F for anyway
right and and like you pointed out the
moment you play c4 you also have to
worry about later Queen a5 but then yeah
then then he feels better about life
what's yeah let's not go age for
actually so see from nature six the
transposition I could play I had an idea
to play Queen before I'm not sure I
would go for that but just kind of to
get this d6 square for the bishop Queen
be for yes also I don't love this move
but maybe it's okay cuz again you can
play Knight d5 for example right and I'm
not sure
yeah I don't know 95 okay but maybe in
this case let's go Bishop c4 I like this
a little better but I like this version
better when I will get this obstacle of
Bishops and should be pleasant for me
still
I assume you go King h8 - yeah sure okay
and I guess I can simply take and
whatever you take probably see before I
can't take with Queen yeah but no
actually should be very good cuz I'll
plant this Bishop on e5 and this should
be very good for me I believe okay so
that's interesting Queen before if I
just want to say it feels a little funny
yeah we like okay I don't know King h8
doesn't move okay great we don't want to
spend forever but that's some of your
thinking right this is g3 okay cuz I
wasn't I was mystified i I mean if I
don't feeling that engine will not like
to move that was good Lou its I'm sure I
know that it's appreciate just seeing
what you were thinking about so yeah
yeah so now as ideas to come out with
his bishops I'm out with the age five
right and I'm assuming you just felt
that if he took on g3 you would be yeah
yeah because yeah all these pawns are on
lights words and it should be it should
be better for it so in another I mean
obviously black has a lot of different
plans here but he could just simply wait
until you castle yes and then and then
do is although I have waiting those to
like use you will see I had a lot of
waste improve before in forecast like I
played c4 and rook e1 and
yeah I can counsel whenever I want I
think so we were discussing after the
game maybe look a five yeah another way
right with the idea also to support age
five from afar and just develop his rook
leave the bishop on c8 yeah yeah okay we
weren't sure after c4 how he should
proceed because the question is whether
h5 is working or not so if it works it's
great but question is doesn't work so
for example h5 I'll try to take and he's
he's not discovery tactics but I don't
know he's got a lot of discovery so
you're gonna oh yeah this is scary
let me just do one I don't know let me
pick one yeah sure okay so now I have a
choice I can be very greedy and take on
f7 but I'm not sure I like that
let's say I just take on e3 simply you
take in a castle
I think this would still be although
compared to the game is definitely
better for example maybe a natural move
would be like the fart to try that try
to fight for lights we're sure yeah yeah
okay I guess I have an advantage but I'm
not sure it's definitely hard to
evaluate time to be five you know yeah I
think beef I hear is definitely
mandatory them otherwise I could play
see funny you would have this I mean you
know I'm sure there's all kinds of
things you can think about you don't
even have to cancel right away I mean
maybe I could start with you do your
studio if it was important to you you
can do it now let's see what I'm worried
about Ripa fine then sure when I can't
castle on Castle by hand
okay so g6 so this is a violent attempt
to go after your Bishop and now you guys
are really gonna do a dance yeah now
we're dance because if he's learning h5
now very serious threat so I wanted to
meet a Trojan h3 that was the idea right
HOH three okay so let's just say put
that on the board if H [ __ ] that D of
this dad's is if h5 then we play h3 and
our beautiful Bishop will live for
another day where it will not only
defend the white king but be a jerk oh
yeah yeah yeah and maybe someday land on
e5 I wasn't 100% sure like if he could
try some attack so for example let's go
G for sure mm-hmm
I wasn't sure where to put Bishop let's
go to maybe I would actually go to e5 to
try to provoke f6 could be useful I
would say 9h for sure
Castle
and yeah he has ideas to to attack me
but I'm not sure they work for example
GF where's an idea and Queen d7 is
another idea but I don't think they they
work to be honest scary though yeah it
looks scary but yeah I think he doesn't
have enough attackers
okay well let's keep going here so g5
yeah the game he played g5 and this was
an important moment actually because
everything like I was thinking just to
go back soon mr. g3 because now there's
no h5 right but the problem was I
thought he could actually still play h5
okay and the concept is if I take he
goes j4 nice and that is okay I don't
think I can take because of night g3 and
if I don't think he's threatening a g7
to pick up position or Queen G fine
right or Queen g5 exactly I was saying
yeah Bishop f4 this or actually bishop
or this between each field yeah so yeah
basically this is what I saw and no it's
I don't think I can actually save
material
I see so okay I can go h3 there's h3 but
then he takes on g3 and Queen g5 which
should be kind of
yeah definitely yeah okay so the
intention is to yeah so I provoked f6
and now the difference is Bishop g3 h5
takes G for now there's no threat
because I have g6 square for Bishop and
he also cut off the Queen so I believe
that so at the very least you can do
that
at the very least yeah right I was
thinking maybe this before but you know
I see I should have a way out okay this
is this is beautiful
all right yes I did I just say it's a
fan watching this maybe not Beto pay
attention the other games this was like
yeah it's fun to hear you explain it
because I was like I don't know I was
also confused right what was happening
so he goes kingi stone I guess just to
get out of this diagonal but I feel the
king is not that safe there as you'll
see in a second because they go c4 and
now there's always these ideas to open
this diagonal and the King might not
feel too comfortable there and so we're
saying that the h5 again doesn't work
for some okay now my idea of h1 I I
wasn't sure if I could take or not to be
honest but I knew that I also had this
move age for which I was also happy with
that is I think he has to try to take on
g3 FG and I think he has to try to
attack g3 Queen d6 behaviour but now I
can just ignore I can take on g5 and now
you'll see what I was saying earlier
after Queen g3 king d2 if he takes with
Queen I go to page 5 and take with pawn
to d5 check right question so what's
nice too is already in these variations
you've foreseen the pocket exactly it's
it's a very nice pocket actually yeah so
safe yeah yeah beautiful
okay Queenie 7 yeah Rubin the one I
really like this move because now I'm
kind of gaining
the zone on the queenside because once
they control all these squares it's very
easy for me and now my idea is just
Queen before all these end games are
very unpleasant and yeah I always meet
HIV with age four so it's just very
difficult that's beautiful
okay Queen f7 ya know Queen b6 idea
Queen c7 yeah yeah yeah now rook e8 he
he wants to meet Queen c7 with rookie 37
right now the promise after h4 I have
these ideas of taking em Bishop h5 see
what exploit the real convenient right
let's draw an arrow for that one okay
yeah and also I guess you've seen this
idea and so yeah just like let's let's
do it and right if he doesn't play
Knight G 3 but now yeah this is this is
already big trouble isn't it I think
it's like yeah it's just a picture I
might go community to on and I can also
castle back with counseling his also
sure so yeah I thought this is very
close to yeah and I'm gonna guess
there's some other violent opening
variation that you're familiar with
where this structure happens yes yeah
okay good well let's roll through this
it seemed like this was lost
yes the main point is okay and say okay
[ __ ] cuz rookie [ __ ] look bad but the
point is if he takes on g3 King g2 Queen
g5 I'm not going to the end game I go
Queen d6 right clear threat Queen c7
yeah yeah can give a check on a5 it
doesn't
do anything because King c2 and now I
think rip kicks b7 is still a threat and
also wreckage [ __ ] so there's just too
much yeah yeah way too much yeah and
this Bishop is like aspect yeah yeah ok
so right this was already big-time
trouble and we just assumed this had to
be losing here because you're okay Bob
well let's roll through it just cuz it
was a nice finish and you had other
moves I figured but this was just yeah I
cleaned it up the best way I want to say
though I predicted this even is like
just do this just play cheap vibe
oh yeah no this is you did the right
thing look at that oh yeah
simple chess oh man yeah that's just
that's yet beautiful game Geoffrey let
me ask you something
it seems to me you are playing you from
the last tournament - I watched you you
like violence and you are playing a lot
of different openings is that right oh
yeah I like yeah I like yesterday you
played the car oh and before I think
normally I think of you this so silly
yeah I don't
[Music]
well we're gonna be found your games
this is great fun and it's gotta be a
hard battle I mean you're going for
2,700 I presume and it's rougher than
all get-out right yo man what do you
think just just real quick what do you
think the biggest challenge is for you
to get to 2,700 I think it's getting
it's a little psychological because I
have been quite stagnant recently for
last maybe two or three years around the
same so it is like watchful it's a huge
milestone and but I'm still very ready
for the challenge and hopefully keep
going all right well you heard it here
we'll be following your games thank you
very much for coming down Thanks
all right so chess fans I think we're
gonna wrap it up there and we will see
you tomorrow same time same place we're
not wrapping it up no we're not wrapping
okay fine we have to have Caleb come in
here and formally wrap it up I think
while he's getting a seat let's just
review Sam ended up drawing the game
real bummer
Igor Friedman of course is a draw
Ganguly is still going on but we're
assuming that's a win that F pawns
question so yeah excellent interview
from from Jeffrey a lot of interesting
thoughts there and why don't we actually
take a quick look at all of our
standings after the action today sure so
in Group A we actually had a draw from
David Health who was the leader going
into today's rounds and a win from
Jeffrey Zhang so that puts them in a
it's high for a first and all the games
have actually been decided in Group A
with Gawain Jones holding another draw
Darius sweets with another draw and
rounding out the section Liam Lee and
Sam Shanklin at half a point and in
Group B
the action isn't quite done yet we
definitely expect Ganguly to wrap up his
game with actually another win he has I
think just a pretty easily winning end
game and so that would actually put him
a full point ahead of the rest of the
section which is an awesome start for
him tied for second would be Sam setting
Daniel Friedman and Gregorio Pirin and
rounding out the group is caboose Ian
and Kovalenko and in Group C we have
Brandon Jacobson with another drum so I
guess assuming more peaceful results
that actually keeps him in the lead a
half point ahead well Shawn drew his
game
Gordievsky also drew his game and this
last game between Nikon's and Howe
Cobian actually has some chest left to
be played so I think at the moment
expecting any even result there another
draw but anything could really still
happen in that one here we see the the
tournament hall a little bit cleared out
just two more games left left in action
and I do when I talk about actually some
exciting upcoming broadcasts that okay
before before we sign out for the day
here actually coming up right after the
summer chess classic is another leg in
the grand chest tour the regulars will
all be there in Croatia coming up just
June 26 through July 8th and we will be
doing I believe some coverage over that
and following Croatia we actually have
another highly setting tournament the
Junior Championship this was the junior
girls championship and for the first
time ever at the u.s. Senior
Championship is going to be held in st.
Louis very exciting stuff definitely a
full summer of chess for us here here at
the Chess Club with that in mind thank
you all for joining us here today once
again I had a blast and some more
exciting chess games some more exciting
results yeah yeah and be sure to join us
again tomorrow at 3:30 for round three
of the summer chest classic all right
bye everybody
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
[Music]
you
[Music]
you